the coat here's another amazing rescue
the coast guard raced bad weather to
rescue all 11 injured survivors from a
plane crash crash in a remote and rugged
part of Alaska the sightseeing plane had
taken off from Prince of Wales Island
near the Gulf of Alaska it was headed to
Ketchikan but went down about 40 miles
southwest of its destination Kris Van
Cleave shows us the dramatic survival
story
Kris good morning good morning it really
was a race to get to these people the
weather was deteriorating and visibility
had dropped to only about a quarter of a
mile when the rescue chopper spotted the
downed plane moments after the Tuesday
morning crash the pilot used his
cellphone to call 911 that he and his 10
passengers all survived but many were
hurt and needed help the single-engine
float equipped two Haviland Otter
crashed about 2,000 feet up a mountain
in rocky terrain it took hours for the
two Coast Guard rescue helicopters to
find them all 11 people had to be
hoisted off the mountain into a chopper
and rushed to a staging area away from
the worsening weather the injuries are
said to be minor something a spokesman
for the Alaska state trooper says
frankly it's tremendous that no one was
killed
Taquan Air has video of the plane on its
Instagram the company owns about a dozen
aircraft it uses largely for sightseeing
tours out of Ketchikan it purchased
another tour operator after a deadly
2015 crash in the same type of plane the
company says it is cooperating with the
NTSB investigation but intends to resume
flying today
Alex dramatic story thank you Chris